what's up reject nation with comic-con
around the corner the best bet there's
gonna be some Marvel news coming out and
today we're gonna watch from the cosmic
Wonder huge marble face for news Wanda
vision Falcon and the Winter Soldier
shang-chi name just a few MCU characters
coming up Warren from the cosmic Wonder
was recently on new rockstars rogue
theory you guys should go check it out
he killed it on there and yes I did
recommend so you owe your victory or any
rookies you got to him
Warren watches are really suck Maude
how's it goin everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel to cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and we have some excellent yeah
why they do that these projects being
old of course shifted marvel's released
because of all the mass score but it
seems like things are slowly starting to
come back and if that happens we get
more and more information about the
shows and movies that we've been waiting
for so we'll break down this news in
this video but first congratulations to
youtube user
Alex ray as one to two 7:06 for being
the winner of the Wolverine Funko pop
gift yeah whatever Alex SEMA that's in
my about Me section and we'll get you
your thunk about we're giving away a
Black Panther Funko pop all you have to
do to enter to win is subscribe to my
channel like this video and leave a
comment
I keep Rhys absque reiben and doing that
or news we have some great news about
your division series I thought that was
visions
belly-first he shared a part of a resume
for somebody who is working on the one
division series and on this we can see
it says one of vision episode one zero
nine role indie stunts but the big
important part here is to pay attention
to where it says episode of one zero
nine typically how they do this is they
state the season first and then the
episode number so it's Season one
Episode nine meaning one vision is going
to have nine episodes in the first
season is ferry way versus then we
thought we were going to get everybody
is Sam's going to be six epic so I'm
gonna Winter Soldier which is six
especially if you consider the fact that
each episode is probably going to be an
and this applies what we've all been
expecting that the one division series
is going to have a serious impact on the
Marvel Cinematic Universe moving forward
yes possibly be the reason why it has so
many episodes and thanks to an update on
Falcon and the Winter Soldier from
Anthony Mackie the Falcon himself we
have a little bit of insight on how
these shows are going to feel in an
interview with variety Anthony Mackie
said this we're shooting it exactly like
a movie everybody who had worked on TV
before was like I've never worked on a
TV show like this the way in which we
were shooting it feels exactly like we
were shooting the movie cut up into the
show so instead of a two-hour movie a
six or eight hour movie some of those
attacks are hurting exercising a normal
TV show that is not what we're going to
beginning instead we're going to be
getting a six to eight hour movie
basically cut up the filming is going to
be like a movie everything is going to
feel like an actual movie which is great
news because we can assume that Marvel
is going to shoot every single Disney
Plus show they have coming out exactly
the same way and this is why all the
shows are going to connect to the MCU
because they basically are movies
they're basically just really longer
movies and also in the interview he
states that they hope to go back to
filming very soon but it also looks like
one project for Marvel Studios could
have already gone back to work and that
is Shane Qi and the legend of the ten
rings a couple of reddit users posted
online a few set photos of a new set
being built and Sydney Australia for
shang-chi and the legend of the ten
rings and according to these reddit
users these were taking a few weeks ago
that's the Scientology production of
shang-chi don't tell you what else gonna
shut us down
Marvel is going to be taking precautions
on everything that they do coming back
to the filming again but it looks like
Sh and cheese production has resumed and
it looks awesome Falcon in the Winter
Soldier one division
Archive series are going to follow not
too long after so great news things are
kind of slowly starting to come back
from Marvel Studios which means that we
shouldn't have that many more delays and
hopefully we don't because I'm ready to
see these six to nine hour movies in the
form of a Disney Plus show so let me
know what you think about this news in
the comments down below are you excited
to see these Disney plushies and which
one are you most excited to see let me
know what you think in the comments down
below don't forget to like this video
and subscribe to stay up-to-date on
everything relating to the MCU a lot of
updates you can follow me on Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof anytime that dude now I did
actually hear see some headlines going
around about what Anthony Mackie said
with how it feels like a six hour movie
I think like some people might now read
into that as being news that is like all
that surprising or like don't they kind
of already do that with an a lot of TV
shows but it's like already feels like a
long movie of sorts hey I mean yeah cool
confirmation of something that I think
we all sort of expected already yeah the
fact that this is being emphasized makes
me think that there's probably gonna be
something different to it where you're
like wow that really does feel like a
six hour movie of sorts I'm sure with
the production budget I'm sure with what
they don't bring to the screen what they
do with mandalorian like that still felt
like a show you know what I mean like it
had the production budget of a movie I
hear it takes like several months to
just put one of those episodes together
not even one of those is all as one hour
long entirely to say six hour movie you
can't just like end it yeah
chop it up into ways that'll work for
cliffhangers and and it'll work as
individual chapters yeah as one big long
arcing story so that you don't leave
people just dangling between
installments yeah yeah Anthony Mackie
was saying that anyone who's worked on
TV and then worked on this says that
this feels like entirely different so
I'm kind of wondering what they might
bring to the landscape that'll make it
feel different I can't put my finger on
it cuz when I look at even the Netflix
Marvel shows they those were all
connected they released them all in one
giant chunk I believe these are going to
be released separately one week apart
the way how they did man
Laurie and if you look at those seasons
and even like stranger things season 3
of the Netflix model they're essentially
telling one long movie but what will
make this different yeah yeah because
everyone's like getting all hyped about
it like it's like a six hour movie but
I'm going isn't that something that
streaming shows have already kind of
been reviewing yeah yeah HBO and and
that's the day I wonder is if that will
translate to what we actually see on
screen or if it's more about the
production approach that they're taking
because like a lot of state I don't know
how all the HBO type shows work but a
lot of TV works in like a week long or a
seven to ten day turnaround of sorts
where you're shooting for a week or so
and then you're assembling the episode
and it's a couple weeks yeah but you
know so this to me also could just be
saying that yeah we spent a few months
on this episode or something like that
you know either way I mean I'm excited
to see what that translates into because
obviously whatever they're doing here on
the fact that they wanted to tie into
the movies I'm sure will equate to some
kind of bulking up of the production
values for at least what you'd expect
from a show I imagine that whatever it's
gonna end up feeling like you know when
Tarantino did his like extended version
of the hateful eight and then put that
on Netflix as a for Parker it doesn't
necessarily feel like a show it feels
like an extended movie yeah just divide
it up maybe that's what it'll feel like
here in a way yeah where I'm like oh
yeah I can see why people are honing in
so much on this like it feels like a six
hour movie idea because I feel like we
already associate that with other shows
yeah I just keep wondering like what's
that model gonna feel like here that
would be entirely different than that
it's gonna be intent it's like when you
watch the six hour cut of any of the
Lord of the Rings movies I feel like a
lot of people break those yeah this
would be that but just already broken up
for you yeah so I don't you think they
would have to at least if it does feel
like a six hour movie wouldn't you have
to release it all at once then as
opposed to weekly installments the way
how the mandolin seems to work out for
Disney Plus to do it that way but if
this is like the pitch that's kind of
going around not from Disney Plus
directly but anthony mackie likening it
to it and this other news about whan
division being nine episodes that it
feels like good no no we're movie you
know yeah well now I'm sitting here
going with all those Marvel
Netflix shows a lot of us were sitting
around going this didn't need to be 9 or
10 episodes it could have been like 6
episodes
yeah with Ron division being as
important as it is I'm not at all
surprised to see that it's a little bit
longer and that's exciting
I think the Netflix shows like 12 to 13
episodes and people were arguing that it
could be like 8 to 9 episodes I think
nine episodes could be a perfect length
to cover it but if it is the only one of
its twenties like you're still don't
really hear anything about Loki all this
time okay Loki was the first one
announced yeah and we rarely hear
anything about it which is something
which is so funny to me if Wanda vision
specifically is getting if the other
ones are six episodes and this one and
Wanda vision is nine episodes that does
show that they do care a little bit more
about the impact of what Wanda vision
should lead to when it makes me wonder
if maybe a Wanda vision will touch the
other shows in any way shape or form
yeah and if there will be any kind of
involvement from like the other cast
members of the shows at least that are
gonna launch in close proximity to
wander yeah and I will also say that
like don't get too excited if people are
resuming production don't get too
excited seriously are you in California
alone just yesterday the bars day like
okay bar set the shut down again and
then there's other states that are now
drew but we got to go back to shutting
things down in Florida shuts down you
know yeah and that's the thing too is I
feel like I'm more excited to hear about
the TV production opening back up
because that is something that you know
we all expect to do at home so I can see
how that might lead to something
tangible for us to watch wears like
shang-chi starting back up I don't want
to see that on TV yeah so until we're
the worlds in a state where I get to see
the movie I I kind of don't care if
they've finished it now or later well
yeah I mean we just got a we can't be -
they might start production they might
have to stop production again you know
that's the way it's going for a lot of
parts in the world I mean the benefit is
there they're not shooting this in the
States and right now it's pretty bad in
the states it isn't getting worse wear
your mask people please wear your mask
and ego and ass don't be one of those
people who are completely against it
where your master no saying that will
upset some of you guys but trust me
you're only know we're only making it
worse there I'm just gonna get upset at
breasts they have to be inconvenienced a
little bit you can bet that when
comic-con rolls around
gonna be getting a trailer for at least
two oh yeah that's what I'm really
excited for can be some teaser for
you'll see alright guys well thanks
Warren for unveiling the news here you
can subscribe to the real rejects
subscribe to cosmic wander click our
notification bell last but not least
Chris Wham off now Chris has been an
amazing amazing friend to us over here
at the real rejects he's a extremely
humble human being who spent so much
time with his work his downtime
contributing to bettering society in any
way he possibly can't getting arrested
for fighting the could ya keep season
he's the real deal
yeah generally he wants like a very
specific thing to be shattered out
whenever we'd give him a shout-out this
time around he said honestly just anyone
getting involved or who donated to the
causes as of late that had been very
prevalent and the zeitgeist shoutout for
all the people who never got a news
article to say thank you for their work
I appreciate you specifically wanting us
to mention that because a lot of times
you know we might only hear about what's
trending or something like that but
there's a lot of people who are going
out of their way right now to make a
major difference in the world you can
too and whatever way you possibly can
even if it's something very little it
contributes to the greater good thank
you Chris Mama for reminding me of such
significance that can come from the
littlest of contributions could because
that can make to the biggest change in
the world you have been someone who's
been very enlightening in my life thank
you for being you do love you bye